I just can't believe the first Asian
Marvel Superhero is such a little boy in
social media
inspirational kinda
yeah
you did a really good David
[Music]
okay a lot of people wanted
um David to be here for this but he's
not so we'll just do it anyway we'll
just be louder than we usually are one
of our followers Nikki sent this and uh
it's pretty good there's a thing that
happened where
um an article was posted
on Huffington Post
all right so that's [__] great so
this is it before we get into it
it just says we love simulu
but he's not the only talented Asian
thirst trap in Hollywood well he could
have been fooled that's not simu no I
know it's an example of a thirst trap in
Hollywood that's not simu so what
happened that's why they wanted David
the thing that's interesting is that uh
it's the way that like the guy who wrote
the article posted it and
added a quote from the article that says
I'm all for an Asian King thriving but
when a single actor gets the bulk of
Asian male roles in Hollywood it feels a
little like tokenism so he's inferring
that this guy's a [__] [__] a lot of
the goals are going to the same Asian
people and honestly shimu said something
that was actually pretty spot on he goes
way to attempt to put us against one
another what bulk of roles are you
referring to are there movies I'm in
that I'm not aware of do you think that
there is a quota of Asian male roles
that is a zero-sum game everything I
have taken post Shang Chi was not
written Asian we've been able to reshape
stories to get more representation on
screen get your facts right and he does
have a point but sometimes he shouldn't
respond
well he's gonna respond see who's gonna
take a wall that's such a long response
to just like a little sentence headline
yeah it wasn't uh Cadets down into the
yeah into the brass tags but I do like
that he is saying like I'm not in every
[__] movie like he's not simu yeah
he's in shangshi but like he's not but
also no [__] right like of course he's
not in every [__] movie is he saying
that like it's the same circle of Asians
that's in every movie because I'm like
yeah I mean that's the Asian Hollywood
group who the [__] else are they gonna
choose for me it's like dude one step at
a time dude we just had Shang Chi
[__] like I don't know a year or two
ago before that the next the last big
movie was crazy Rich Asians were making
[__] strides once that better time
stopped complaining you [__] little
[__] I guess what the what the writer
of the article Ian Kumamoto is kind of
trying to say is that I think he's
trying to shine a light on more unsung
heroes within the Asian actor to say it
like that
tie a little bit
down Steam
oo clicks baby it's controversial yeah
come on yeah and it gets to include
simulu's name in the headline and he
knows he was going to respond because
yeah because he has no [__] skin yeah
he takes it all dude he can't wait he
can't wait to get [__] about it but just
the way that it looks we're like if
you're gonna say that quote and then put
a picture of simu it's kind of like why
are you going after that particular
thing I just can't believe the first
Asian Marvel Superhero is such a little
[__] boy in social media
it's inspirational kinda
Anthony you had something you wanted to
add I'm trying to be David here
you did a really really good David oh
David I made two
more strengths and and just not talking
to peasants you know like you're I mean
seamless achieved such a high point like
do you see Will Smith commenting to like
haters Will Smith might be a bad example
he did slap someone but he slapped this
rock he didn't slap some hate on the
street right imagine oh okay that's the
thing that he's doing that's what I'm
saying is like this guy like seem was
achieved a very high pillar when you're
like royalty at this point what are you
doing fighting with peasants yeah yes
but also like because he's using his
name to get some clouds oyster Kumamoto
guys
it's not like
it's not like he's ripping out Michelle
Yao for like bagging all her rolls
because she kind of always consistently
she took roles for like decades get
after her then right he's not hating on
her and none of us are hating on him I'm
not saying anything bad about it
I love her she's thought she's killing
it harder than simu is in that same
concept but he's not hitting on her you
know like so it's like it seems a little
bit just but really [__] about this
guys but this this but this happens all
the time in Hollywood right like someone
becomes like the hot thing and then
everyone wants to book them so then they
get like they secure five ten movies
after that big hit same thing happened
to a lot of members like like in the
past of like or like so for example Cuba
Gooding right when he came out with
hustle and floor or whatever or no no no
no [__] um the other guy parents
Howard Terrence Howard okay yeah he kept
going one after the other he did have
some yeah he got he got paid way more
than Robert Downey Jr Iron Man well
that's also that's also in part due to
10 picture deals and things that people
get behind the scenes that we don't even
know about yeah like Paramount Pictures
will sign someone for multiple movies
the thing about see mulu is like he is a
household name in a lot of ways right so
it's kind of in the interest of the
media to punch up all right yeah like
it's that's kind of the thing right like
dude these guys like who we're talking
about here these guys get paid by the
article right they're they're
contractors right or um they're what do
they what the [__] you call it non-union
non-contractor what the [__] yeah well
it does say he's a guest writer yeah
exactly so like they're not even part of
a place they're just trying to punch up
as much as they can to get as much
attention as they can to boost their own
and you can't punch too far up because
then they won't reach bad you gotta
punch that something that you think is
close enough because like and SEMA will
respond you're not he's not writing
about Jackie Chan no right yeah because
he knows Jackie Chan's not even gonna
[__] ever respond ever but he knows
that seemu will punch back all those emu
will dude my little brother could write
an article about simulu my little
brother is a [__] I.T guy who lives
in Missouri
that's an article about Seafood
paragraphs simulu will take three days
to think of the perfect response and
because
right now is the shield for Asian
America like he's like he's a poster boy
he's a captain Asian American it's like
insane though he kind of is
like he has this duty of like I have
this duty to [__] say something
wasn't he in the NBA All-Star game like
the the celebrities yeah he wasn't still
realized how many of the Asian dudes
were on the All-Star Game none I think
it's just him so in a lot of ways he is
like the PO he's the guy and when you're
the and all power to him like get your
bag of course I think it's just like
yeah like Steve says or like you already
know he's gonna [__] clap back and
that you don't need to do that and
they're working him that's all look I
got no hate for you bro I swear to God I
know you're watching this because you
watched everything
but I'm just saying dude like you gotta
just be you bro you'll be fine boo
you'll be fine yeah just be you your top
dog right now for you your top G you do
and by the way when he responds to
things where he's like yeah like you
know we made like hundreds of millions
of dollars like it's crazy like I'm so
surreal like but I'm the [__] mankind
also it's like good for you honestly
that's [__] tight stay there stay
there don't get down in the ditch with
these [__] asses exactly because
they're benefiting off of they're using
him like frustrating him basically they
can rock the boat on him right they're
rocking the boat on them it's they're
literally just it's like answering to
the troll it's like David David's uh
rocking the boat yeah and it works they
was rocking the boat dude it raises
David's profile a million times
he's running code too that's not what
David sees what I see and that's the
thing I'm a troll right I see the blood
in the water on this guy and I know you
can shake him and get you what you want
you know when someone's gonna get their
panties in a bunch you want to poke
because it's funnier it's like making
fun of him nobody likes watching anyone
get dunked on on this whole Channel more
than that guy his head is a basketball
that our fans have turned into a meme of
me dunking it right this guy right here
literally literally a meme because
because we all get so much joy because I
go home tonight and I [__] write
paragraphs about what I'm gonna say to
Steve and then I come here and then I
blank out
I wish that was true I do I wish I owned
your brain that much I don't but that's
the thing I know you're you're you are
not you don't take yourself that
seriously and if I could give simulu one
nobody should right exactly just don't
take yourself so seriously bro I feel
like with simu having so much attention
and he cares about the community so much
and there's so many Asians telling him
you need to stand up you need to talk
back you need to do this that is true
he's under blood pressure he's under
from a guy like us we're like dude chill
no you don't have to carry the weight
weight of Asian America you that's not
your job put me in a movie I'll [__]
carry some weight for you but the thing
is
he does have a lot of Asians telling him
hey not only are your inspiration it's
your [__] duty to say something
superhero you are Shang Chi he's never
gonna please everybody right yeah you
gotta just chill out a little bit right
Marvel hates you so much they didn't
give you a costume just chill out but by
him being there in a lot of ways it just
kind of sets the path anyway like just
him existing by him being there he
doesn't have to say anything
moves the needle so far that like he's
he's the guy he's the man like do you
guys see that video of uh Michael B
Jordan on the Creed set like he was on
the red carpet or something and this
girl who he went to high school with
yeah yeah interviewed him and then she's
like oh how does it feel to be Michael
whatever the [__] right ask him some
questions he's like yeah we used to know
each other back in the day and then he
claps back on her because he remembers
when her and her friends used to call
him corny back in the day when they were
like kids when he had his head shots at
school and he's like oh like I'm corny
right I'm corny you called me corny blah
blah and your mind you're like Michael B
Jordan bro you are one of the biggest
stars in the world one of the sexiest
[__] alive you could have her
contract killed tonight and nobody would
even say a word you yeah dude you're the
director you're the star of this million
dollar 100 million dollar franchise
and you're like punching down on the
like you don't have to say a thing to
this lady like you already called corny
is nothing well it's also because she
was trying to if you're in high school
bro she was trying to act like they were
friends back in day like verbally to his
face yeah he was like you made fun of me
for sure my friend but wouldn't it be
kind of more a gangster move if he just
was got her killed yeah got her killed
bro just do the contract killer it's
even more gangster for him to go yeah we
were best friends they sleep together
that night and then he goes but I don't
want you oh
that's gangster that's gangster
he's [__] her that night right and
then he's like [__] corn he's a [__]
[__] corn oh yeah call me corny boy
call me corny [__] yeah
it's like bro you already won you're
Michael B Jordan you know what I think
it is I think like for okay so guys like
us who get it we see insecurity while
other people see empowerment they might
see that and go thank you for standing
up for us because they're weak guys that
wished they could stand up and say [__]
right for us I'm just like I actually
see strength and stoicism so if these
things don't affect you and you laugh
and not only do you laugh you make fun
of them and make them look stupid I'm
like that's not only a level of
confidence but intelligence and strength
exactly right you don't have to be like
actually fool yeah you know what I mean
like that that to me it just feels a
little bit like oh you don't have to you
don't have to take it so seriously you
little man stop being little don't be
little and I don't mean he is little I
just mean he's acting little like when
you do that you're acting smaller than
you are you've obviously done a lot of
great things you could talk about it you
can show people I've done a lot of great
things look at all those box office
success that we had all this [__] but
then when you're acting little when
you're like doing four paragraph
responses some peon and [__] Gawker
yeah like who gives the doctor I do I in
this article though they do this writer
does say something that I'm like God it
says all we're saying is we don't want a
predominantly white Hollywood to gate
keep sexy Asian male represent what's we
and who's we I don't know but the main
that's him all I'm saying don't say we
yeah the weird thing is that what this
article is doing it's doing what White
media has always done to White Hollywood
which is divide opinions on people who
were just doing good and I find that
weird I'm like absolutely you're an
Asian writer doing the thing you don't
want white Hollywood to do yeah well
oyster cumamoto it's the same game right
exactly they're still playing that same
game in the same area they're trying to
get clicks because at the end of the day
they got us right they do we got got
guys we got God by Huffington Post
foreign